mais pas dit ce qui compte maintenant ce
n'était pas des skieurs en platière
mastic et on n'avait pas de charnières
de sécurité nous y en avait pas de
chaussures qu'on ne peut pas marcher
avec les chaussures de maintenant o o
il faut trois choses qui est pour entrer
dans deux démos qu'ne pour en sortir
ouais si t'as pas les outils tu couches
avec les chaussures nous 7 et des savons
qu'en clouet sur les skis comme ça la
sécurité elle était toute trouvée
tu tombé par l'iss qui continuait tout
seul il allait chercher du secours
grâce tu as on n'avait pas besoin de
faire des trucs compliqués n'ai pas
besoin de faire l'offre nous installent
leur demande un peu où bien des trucs
impossibles comme le le chat ce n'est
mon le chasse-neige cardiff ansa on
croirait toujours qu'ils ont fait caca
dans l'arc sûrs que des fois que c'est
vrai
ou bien des trucs impossibles comme
comme les cristina morelli christina moi
j'y connais rien c'est un moniteur qui
me l'a dit il paraît que christina c'est
un virage qu'on peut faire d'un seul
coup ça s'arrête il ya quatre chargés de
qu'à moi on m'a toujours dit qu'il
fallait pas changer de caravanes qui
souhaitent tous les deux ans n'arrête
les deux car le chauffeur ne veut par
monts et puis nous dans le temps
faux on monte à pied maintenant c'est de
te de ski d'été des belles d'été de
féric il franchetto des trucs comme ça
rien que pour des armes
vous croyez que c'est du sport vous une
heure de cusset minutes de dessin pour
j'ai vu ce que c'était moi je vous le
dis nous tu aurais vu 14 21 ski picore
descendait à plat var depuis la visière
la forêt montlieu la poussière tu aurais
vu voilà maintenant on n'y comprend rien
il défriche des arts veille coupe des
arbitres des friches des nouvelles fils
calque ses défricher dia plus d'âme il
plane des piquets pour faire exprès de
tourner autour
du stade l'homme qu'ils appellent ça du
slalom moi j'appelle ça des singeries
autour d'une forêt drame de point man et
on ignore c'est plus ce que c'était
et puis et puis les demoiselles qui
viennent au ski en les way bien par chez
nous on est placé pour les demoiselles
qui viennent au ski ce serait pas plutôt
pour l'après-ski s'écartant way la
grenouille au wat tout de suite le son
qu'elle peut faire
[Musique]